yeah and when to apply them to this
video playing yeah so 64 I think you
place the Kings Indian I have some
recollection there you
so the Petrosian once again you played
something with an early night to see
five that's what I remember
yeah does it again Jim what is the point
there's some weird stuff them with with
with night sex and so on Queen sex I
mean I think there is
I would have some I had to set us
against him
in an earlier game Terry Sean 9h 5 and
so on yeah a little of them of the game
there was I think we had precisely this
pollution and then you played some you
played some some g5 or something
yeah I think you played g5 maybe in
precisely this position and that didn't
work out at all okay just goes back and
make some sense out of the Queen go
angling for g5 25 it's annoying annoying
move prepare what you won in this case
don't like it so much feels like some
maybe have some way to open up him that
is favorable to black yeah maybe he has
some does he have some intermediate move
I don't see it at the moment I don't
think he has
if not I'm fine
I have 94 no he doesn't have an
intermediate move then this position is
okay
Oh interesting so if I take it and I
wonder where to go here I'm a G 3 or C 3
let's go C 3
yeah the bishops are not that great here
given the complete static nature of the
position even Queen f2 is a move that I
would like to play with 20 not good my
ideal of course to break through okay
Bishop h6 to f4 that doesn't work why
can I not just takes e5 like we do for
probably came prepared e6 I had almost
the same kind of thing asked against him
in it earlier game if I take now he gets
some he gets what you for so going to
just keep everything coordinated okay
eight so g3 is going to play Queen e7
then 95 that looks pretty good
[Music]
I've also give necessary to cyclic win
so I can check here takedown doesn't
feel completely convincing check I
cannot really attack this Kim and some
improve this position a little bit low
on
so I take it please loop is 6ir okay so
I should probably play this move
prepared reform III maybe we might play
III in this position just try to open
open this arm and I burps get strong
it's not let's not completely completely
simple you three looks like an
interesting choice okay
I will just overlooked something he can
he can protect the pawn here probably
with Bishop III not good that's not good
at all and now the bishop move we should
be form the set lease leads to a very
murky situation okay I can enter I can
enter with the Queen and let the king
take care of this but I don't know let's
take care that it's time warning check
check and I'm the king over here I must
be must be winning I don't I don't think
that can work
so should can still can still cannot
move
I cannot play c4 because of f5 I didn't
see this one check I don't know check
here okay
looks pretty bad but am i winning I
don't see you win
check-check
[Music]
23 is threats
check check check check check check
ah I didn't can't think you would go
there check like for fit on time
yeah the way the game went I don't
really feel all that bad to win on time
okay so um let's have a look down Jim I
think that this change of structure
doesn't work for black I mean he should
be okay of course now the pieces are
reasonably active and it doesn't have
any immediate problem but I don't know I
think this is this in combination with
taking leads to problems because here
the remaining the structure is just too
bad and this breakthrough just leads to
a complete wreckage I mean I can take
the success the engine suggests but I
just wanted for control you know I mean
I don't know does he have to take I
wasn't so sure I thought maybe you can
still do this move but then I can take I
mean that wasn't my intention
maybe giving the Queen was actually the
better choice
okay g-force better yeah I should have
played this is some I should take
oh yeah I see I stopped this calculation
too early I can do this this and then
this is a strong move taking this next I
didn't see Queen f3 33 yeah that would
have made the thing relatively easy to
win but this is some check at least from
a practical point of view isn't that
easy
yeah but yeah I should win but as we saw
and there were some some issues I should
probably take that's easier
25 25 wins I didn't really quickly I
didn't see a single simple move check
check and here I mean there probably
many mistakes Kenny but with the time
situation yeah Queeny six wins and okay
we both had ten seconds okay guys thanks
for watching